welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the falcon the winner soldier
released a first full official trailer
at disney's investor day proving you
don't need cap for a great looking cap
story aside from cap shield and cap's
iconography and cap's best friends and
cap's past enemies fighting over his
legacy
shut up whatever this six episode series
is coming to disney plus
march 2021 and it looks sick with great
callbacks to past mcu films and
intriguing marvel easter eggs setting up
how phase 4 could reach forward
sam wilson may not have a plan but
clearly kevin feige does
so let us break it down frame by frame
for everything that you might have
missed in this trailer here we go
[Music]
the legacy of that shield is
complicated right the trailer opens at
cap's exhibit at the smithsonian a
collage
shows these headlines of events that we
saw in that first captain america film
when cap liberated the 400 prisoners
which
included bucky and howling commandos
there's the famous captain america
number one comic in which cap punches
hitler which cap reenacted on his
warbonds tour
there's his famous 4f paperwork when
skinny steve was initially denied and
the moment he used the star
corridor as a shield foreshadowing his
own famous tool
but of these most interesting to me is
the headline from that episode nazis in
new york mystery man saves child
a headline that i find very ironic
because before pearl harbor folks there
totally were proud nazi sympathizer
rallies in new york
they booked freaking madison square
garden a scary amount of americans were
chill with nazis those days
in fact cap punching hitler was a bold
controversial political stance joe simon
jack kirby they got death threats for
that
so god bless those men for doing it and
i hope this series keeps that spirit
alive fighting the good fight fighting
fascism something we sadly have to stay
vigilant to these days now among these
antiques collecting dust is
no antique that is capp's shield in fact
his new shield that was one given to sam
by old cap and
end game you can tell by the new notches
the new carved out elongated hexagonal
inserts which were not there on the
previous shield the one that probably
does belong in a museum but it ended up
on an in-game scrap pile somewhere
severed in half
now i have theorized that since the most
logical explanation for cap's return at
the end of the game is that he must have
lived out his life in an
alternate history and then somehow
quantumed back to this one
quantum mania don't meet in-game
screenwriters it's weird to have two
caps in history at the same time old
history cap shield might be constructed
out of
its classic substance in the comics
proto-adamantium
and it might have secret functions
activated uniquely by sam wilson and
here the super imposition of sam with
this shield suggests yeah he's about to
steal this thing the way cap stole his
own classic uniform from the same
exhibit in winter soldier now
sam hints at this particular shield's
bizarre history by saying its legacy is
complicated which is really the theme of
this series
when cap bore the shield no one could
refute that he was the same guy who
first carried it in the 40s but now that
he's out of the picture the shield
represents something bigger than any one
man
it's kind of like the country it
represents right the warriors who have
fought behind it are really just too
mixed of a bag too many competing
interests
for this one symbol to truly shield them
all
also the way the organization shield has
failed too many people
it is complicated so too has this relic
at what looks like the wilson family
home sam and bucky are there probably
the same scene where sam practices
discus tossing that field and now you'll
notice all the trunks are strapped with
padding
maybe sam lumberjacked one two mindy
trunk now one last detail before i move
on look closely and you can see
bucky is wearing his dog tags under his
shirt now how did he get them back
because
hydra recovered him after his fall and
then he was thought to be dead but he
was actually alive as a winter soldier
on behalf of hydra for decades and
decades and that would make him an
enemy to the us government and who would
have had their hands on the tags that
time
probably hydra right now zemo did get
his hands on that winter soldier box
maybe he had them and then he returns
into bucky when they meet in this series
on to the next clip
the world
it's upside down okay this section shows
this interesting looking asian city
we know this to be madrapore a fictional
nation in marvel comics it's near
singapore it's a corrupt town consisting
of a high town
section which is kind of for the elite a
global tax haven for crime syndicates
and then for the scum and villainy
the lowtown hive of drug dens you can
kind of see that blade runnery contrast
here the futuristic skyscrapers
gazing right over the dirty street level
which features an interesting eclectic
mix of languages on the signs
so along with sokovia wakanda i am
thrilled to see
this series expanding the mcu map of
fictional settings that have been on
earth the whole time and
major poor is interesting to wolverine
comics which would set up some
interesting implications for how this
setting could later be used to introduce
x-men in the mcu now i may be wrong but
leading sam and bucky here on the
walkway looks like the coat in the
slicked hair of
zemo now despite the obvious bad blood
between them
zemo did try to destroy the avengers and
did mind control
frame bucky for murder there may still
be a shared goal
especially if you consider that sam and
bucky remain fugitives under the skovia
accords then we see some german guards
and riot gear running past some inmates
facing wall this must be the prison that
zemo was kept in after civil war and now
we are seeing the day of his escape
because yeah now we know he's not in
that prison anymore then this close-up
showing sparks scraping into some
spilled gas to ignite a blaze based on
those boots and pants we might be
looking at our old friend batroc the
leaper who
is expected to return in the series as
well then an explosion rocks a stack of
shipping containers it kind of looks
like a lab of some kind was inside
one of those those shipping containers
do show up again in other shots and
might be connected to the truck sequence
which has some shipping containers there
then a shot of aaron kellyman's
character who straps an
interesting mask on her face it's got a
red hand print
two other females run behind her with
similar masks past this truck that looks
like there are some prisoners inside
one of those could be zemo maybe this
group hijacked a prisoner transport and
are now breaking out zemo
now this group is confirmed to be called
the flag smashers now in the comics
flagsmaster is a solitary cat villain
here it has been turned into a group
many thought those handprints and the
connection to magipore could mean this
could be the hand
but now this group doesn't strike me as
an ancient order of ninjas now a lot of
you have been asking me why i think this
is songbird well there were some set
reports describing a scene with
kellerman's character in which she has a
phone that releases a specific sonic
frequency that activates other people's
phones and lures them in via a kind of
mind control
which is very similar to the power of
songbird who
is a member of the thunderbolts for now
she just seems to be part of this group
the flag smashers which
might later be turned into a
thunderbolts type of group especially if
zemo is heading up this group beazemo as
citizen v
started the thunderbolts with songbird
part of that and before i continue thank
you to our friends at skillshare for
sponsoring this video
skillshare is an online learning
community that offers membership with
meaning with so much to explore
real projects to create and the support
of fellow creatives skillshare
empowers you to accomplish real growth
skillshare offers classes designed for
real life you can learn and grow with
short classes that fit any schedule
this holiday season give a gift that
means more get creative and learn how to
make the perfect
handmade gift with skillshare's online
classes they have classes and topics new
rockstars fans will appreciate like
animation film video music production
the class i really want to check out is
creative writing crafting personal
essays with impact taught by
best-selling author roxanne gay
the class focuses on how to find your
story craft your truth
and write to make a difference at a time
when so many important conversations are
happening in our world your voice is
more essential than ever
explore classes to unlock your
creativity for social good
skillshare is curated specifically for
learning there are no ads
and they're always launching new premium
classes so you can stay focused and
follow wherever your creativity takes
you and it's less than ten dollars a
month with an annual subscription and
the first 1000 people to use the link in
the description will get a free trial of
skillshare premium membership
so you can explore your creativity next
clip
people need something to get behind
okay now we see the southern home from
the water which i'm just guessing as
someone from the south it looks a lot
like georgia south carolina north
carolina
and you can see how sam's family runs a
fishery and seafood business there's a
sign behind them
on the pier that reads wilson family
seafood fresh shrimp oysters clam yum
yum yum yum yum yum so here it is folks
convert the falcon in the winter soldier
is showing us what would have happened
if forrest gump and bubba were
superheroes
you ever been on a real shrimp boat sam
drops a bulky
super gear suitcase presumably
containing his or bucky's gear
bucky talks about how the world is
upside down people just need something
to get behind suggesting that neither of
them are society's pick for a cap
successor instead of the one society
chose is wonder bread john walker us
agent four on him in a bit but there's
another shot of magipore and then sam
and bucky geared up taking off
including if you look closely sam's red
wing drone then we see zebo standing
before
this memorial statue that crowned eagle
is the crest of
sokovia you can see zakovian flags and
lettering on the base
the broken terrain in crater lake was
likely created by sekovia being
clawed out of the ground and then lifted
and then dropped back down which killed
a ton of cycobians
including zemo's family i love this
there's a lot left to explore in socobia
i theorized ultron's return
but we have also learned from the
wakandaphiles book that hydra initially
chose sokovia because of its higher than
normal concentration
of those with genetic dispositions open
to mind stone enhancements in other
words
a mutant hotspot so like match reports
sokovia is another region marvel could
dig deeper into when they are ready to
introduce the x-men
and then this shot that we've seen
before bucky's vibranium hand dropping
bullets in front of zemo maybe bucky's
dramatically refusing to work with zemo
moving on
i need a symbol
so what's our plan
okay next this football game that we saw
back in the big game spot in which
phony cap u.s agent john walker trots
out he's played by wyatt russell
u.s agent is one of the many wannabe
replacement cat figures in marvel comics
originally he was the wrestler super
patriot and if you look over
to the right on that field is this
blonde woman i'm wondering if this could
be
sharon carter who's expected to be part
of the show maybe she is part of the new
government pr
operation to try to introduce this new
cap even though he's never going to
happen
we follow sam and bucky into this club
to the far right it's a figure with a
tablet sam looks like he's about to
hand them his phone to be brought into a
vip area but then next this
shot of this truck sequence sam pulls a
kind of clark griswold from christmas
education
slides right under that truck i have no
idea how sam wouldn't just
immediately lose upward lift and fall
flat on his face on that road but yeah
whatever it looks really cool now also
on this truck is cali man's character
and if you look at the wide shot you can
barely make out i think that's bucky
there definitely a us
agent and a handful of others as someone
else hangs from the helicopter overhead
now if you look at that road sign behind
them it looks like this is part of the
german autobahn
and there are these two trucks that are
nearly identical
making me think that part of this
mission is to hijack one of these
shipping containers and maybe swap it
out for another identical one it's hard
to know what side bucky's on here though
because in a later shot near a similar
looking shipping container he appears to
provide
cover fire for two women who look like
they're part of that flag smasher crew
then there's a mid-air explosion from a
helicopter and you can see falcons
soaring past it to the right there looks
like he drew some of those missiles
right into the second enemy aircraft and
then bucky and falcon fleet this magic
war motorcycle gang set photos reported
one of these bikers wearing a jacket
with a red demon face that resembles
ogun that is a marvel comics figure tied
to wolverine's backstory i'm just gonna
keep bringing this up in case wolverine
does end up being brought up in the show
but then to the right are some horse
statues you know like the ones that you
might see on a carousel or outside a
supermarket i i don't know what to make
of this other than the low town magikarp
sounds terrifying then sam
fights kellyman's character and then
bucky calls back his signature knife
flip the one that we saw him do when he
was the winner soldier in captain
america winter soldier i love this it's
such a cool move showing how nimble he
must have gotten with his real hand
since you know it's the only real hand
he has left
alright next clip
so no plan
right another great callback in this
clip
sam jumping out of that plane just like
how cap loves jumping out of aircrafts
sans parachutes but you know it's also
just like sam to
wing it like this i'll see myself out
you can watch the next clip
whoa baby the stunt choreography of
falcon through this canyon just
looks incredible especially the moment
he retracts his wings he does that
little flip through the gap and you'll
notice mackie
looks down as he has to use his actual
limbs
to briefly touch and kick off from some
of that rock before he ascends again the
big game spot showed brief shots of
another skydive sequence with a point
break style gunfire that may be part of
the plan that bucky has to resort to
then on to the title shot
[Music]
now over this close-up animation of
falcon swings bucky's vibranium arm we
hear the series title music which sounds
like an alteration
of the captain america theme
yeah they really are trying to evoke the
feel of those sam and bucky scenes in
civil war this is
essentially a fourth cat movie i'm very
excited on to the final clip what's
going on in that cyborg brain of yours
you don't want to know oh yeah i can see
it working
gear's turning oh they're malfunctioning
they're on fire
god i hate you ah this trailer leaves us
with just a taste of the banter between
these two ending with bucky calling back
the i hate you moment from civil war
you couldn't have done that earlier i
hate you
but bye-bye look closely here this
callback must have been added in post
because notice that sebastian stan
is clearly mouthing something completely
different in that moment that's where
the audio sounds a little different
they're on fire now i know it's disney
plus but let us assume he's just really
letting sam have it they're on fire
buster you old horny [ __ ] now you have
to check out my breakdowns and reactions
of everything coming out of this
investor day panel including my in-depth
breakdown of the loki trailer and coming
soon my breakdown of the one division
trailer there's a lot of easter eggs
talking about also be sure to check out
our great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com
subscribe to rockstars hit that
notification button follow me at ea boss
following the rockstar thank you for
watching
boom drop it at his feet i'm like boom
you looking for this
[Music]
you